So I was at this one concert the other day.
Oh yeah. Who'd you see?
Sgt. Tamaki's Ouran Host Club Band.
Uhm... is that guy staring at us?
That's REALLY creepy.
I think it's just a cardboard piece.
But who would put a cardboard cutout facing out their office window all night?
Maybe it's just to scare away burglars.
Yeah, guess you're right.
Thanks for watching Being Watched.
Or I guess I should say, thank you for watching the Microhorror entitled Being Watched.
Cause I could see how that might be confusing.
If you haven't already checked out BryceMakesFilms, this is your last warning.
I mean... click over here and check it out,
because the internet is a free country.
So I know my channel says, "monthly horrors",
but I figured since it's October and you subscriber people are pretty cool,
--by the way, there's over 1000 of you now, so thank you sooo much,
and just keep doing that.
So I figured since it's October I would just upload a whole bunch of videos.
So on that note, be sure to leave what you're doing for Halloween in the comments,
and you'll be seeing more of me very soon.
What?